hallo mein Name ist zu kommen meine
Damen und Herren ich darf euch heute
recht herzlich
diese epische Musik regt nur auf ne wir
alle wissen dass mein Content absolut
gar nichts mit irgendwas epischen zu tun
hat
[Musik]
dennoch habe ich heute mal wieder ein
paar lustige WhatsApp Chats rausgesucht
die hoffentlich keinen kompletten in PC
Rumo haben werden na was hast du heute
in der Schule gemacht nix
seit 200 Jahren der beliebteste Dialog
zwischen Eltern und Kindern beim Essen
es war immer so immer so oh warte wie
war es in der Schule gut immer dann
gleich auch wenn sie übel beschissen
zwei mal gut weil einfach keinen Bock zu
reden
[Musik]
hab ein Fahrrad vom Osterhasen bekommen
wo war das denn versteckt im Garten
meines Nachbarn ein wirklich sehr gutes
Versteck
ja
Jugendklasse ruft ich wollte gerade was
ausdrucken und ich zum Drucker könntest
du mir das bitte ausdrucken Drucker ja
klar aber zuerst zeige ich dir alle
Geräusche die ich kann ich schwöre euch
ein Drucker
macht bevor er anfängt zu drucken Sonne
übelste Transformer Geräuschkulisse das
ist unfassbar meine Lehrer haben mich
früher immer für meine unleserliche
Handschrift in den Hausaufgaben
kritisiert dabei lag es nicht an mir
sondern eher am Fahrstil der Busfahrer
das habe ich immer so bewundert an
diesem Bus Kindern ne wenn die auch Bus
Kinder wir haben die früher immer Bus
Kinder genannt nein einfach auf dem Weg
zur Schule ihre Hausaufgaben noch
voneinander abschreiben ich saß auf dem
Fahrrad hat mich abgestrampelt kam
übelst verschwitzt und stinken überhaupt
erstmal in der Schule an und musste dann
in der Pause die Hausaufgaben
abschreiben
ich weiß dass mein Hausaufgaben
eigentlich zu Hause machen sollte aber
wer hat denn Zeit für sowas eine Mutter
hat Angst dass ihr Sohn schwul wird weil
die Kita eine Regenbogengruppe hat
ergibt Sinn ich war damals in der
Bärengruppe heute lebe ich in einer
Höhle im Wald und das ist genau die
Sache
es hat nichts zu tun mit irgendwie in
dem Regenbogen hier oder irgendwas da
oder keine Ahnung was sondern einfach
nur das was die Leute wollen
meine Kindergartengruppe ist einfach
gespensterhaus
ich bin jetzt auch hier immer nachts
unterwegs und fliegt durch irgendwelche
Häuser Menschen
kennst du diesen Moment wenn du dir das
Auge reibst aber nicht aufhören kannst
weil es sich gut anfühlt Orgasmus
das
ist tatsächlich ein ziemlich guter
Begriff wenn dein Auge juckt unbedingt
reiben oder nicht und dann reibst du
kannst dich aufhören das fühlt sich so
unfassbar gut an ich schaue erst letzte
mit verschlafenen Augen auf die Uhr 6:1
yeah noch eine halbe Stunde
weiterschlafen lachkick ich musste auch
mal um 6:30 Uhr aufstehen später schaue
ich wieder auf die Uhr es ist immer noch
6:01 Uhr es war das Datum und ich hätte
längst Aufstehen sollen verdammt
das ist doch natürlich nicht so gut
hattet ihr generell mal so eine
Situation wo ihr richtig verpennt habt
bei mir war es einmal so da musste ich
ein Zug nehmen damals wo ich mein Buch
geschrieben habe das ist eine Biografie
bei meinem Leben meine Mama hat das
geschrieben und ich habe quasi so das
Buch dann bekommen und habe dann alle
möglichen Anmerkungen durchgestrichen
meiner Anmerkung angeschrieben und so
und da sollte meine Mama dich nach
Frankfurt fahren und ich bin von Köln
losgefahren und meine Mom von uns zu
Hause von Bielefeld aus meiner Mom war
schon fast da und ich bin gerade
aufgewacht weil ich hatte am Tag vorher
noch Uni boah und das hat ein bisschen
länger gedauert und dann wieder alle auf
mich gewartet und ich dann irgendwie
nach Frankfurt gerast das war schlimm
ich hatte aber auch mal das Gegenteil
und zwar war ich krank im Winter und bin
schlafen gegangen und meine Uhr hatte
nicht diese dass sie ab 12 Uhr dann 13
wieder 1 Uhr an auch wenn es ein und
nachmittags ist und ich habe so
verschlafen dass ich aufgewacht bin weil
mein Mittagsschlaf und es war irgendwie
so 6:30 Uhr oder irgendwie so ich dachte
ich müsste dann zur Schule aber
Mittagsschlaf ist einfach so eskaliert
dass es einfach 18:30 Uhr war und ich
habe mich dann geduscht fertig gemacht
zum Frühstück und diese es ist Abend die
Situation gab es auch nicht Quatsch
irgendwie viel zu viele dem heutigen
Video ein Kollege von mir hat gerade
einen Arbeitsunfall gemeldet das ist
doch nicht lustig er war vorhin im
Krankenhaus und ist nun zwei Wochen
krankgeschrieben und was ist passiert er
hat sich beim Gähnen den Kiefer
ausgerenkt da fällt mir echt nichts mehr
ein also das ist wirklich die dümmste
Verletzung die ich je gehört habe
telefongesprächslänge Vater mit Sohn 12
Sekunden somit Vater 15 Sekunden so mit
Mutter zwei Minuten 15 Junge mit Mädchen
eine Stunde 36 und 30 Sekunden Mädchen
mit Mädchen 12 Stunden 50 Minuten 35
Sekunden junge Anrufe verpasst
das ist einfach wirklich nur die
Wahrheit bringst du noch Wein für uns
für heute Abend mit klar welchen suche
ein aussetzungspasst billig und knallt
gut
das sind so richtig diese
40-jährigen die aber so möchte gern jung
noch sein wollen und dann so in Köln
über die Ringe schlendern und unseren
Junggesellenabschied feiern und jedem
irgendwie so ein pinken ekelhaft süßen
shot in die Hand drücken und rumkriechen
ein Jahr lang
der mit mir geschrieben
jetzt nicht mehr
ich brauche vielleicht einen neuen
Kugelschreiber
das ist das ist alles wirklich Sonne NPC
Humor heute habe ich mal meine Leber
überrascht wie das hat zur Abwechslung
mal Wasser getrunken an der Stelle ganz
ganz liebe Grüße Sandra ich habe gerade
mein Freundebuch aus der dritten Klasse
gefunden und was steht drin Lena
Doppelpunkt Foto kommt noch scheiß Lena
scheiße das waren keine richtigen
Freunde wenn jemand ein wirklicher
Freund oder eine wirkliche Freundin von
dir war dann hat er oder sie sich die
Zeit genommen ein Foto ausdrucken da
reinzukleben und generell jedes Feld
auszufüllen schreibt mal in die
Kommentare als wäre das ein Freundebuch
schreibt man so rein was sein Name ist
wie alt ihr seid was eure Hobbys sind
Augenfarbe Größe ich mache eine Liste
mit gewässerwort Spielen lass mal sehen
habe erst drei nicht mehr
oh weia
das ist genau mein Humor
ich kann darüber aber gerade nicht
lachen
was im Umkehrschluss heißt dass mein
Humor ziemlich beschissen ist
zugelassene Hilfsmittel bei der Klausur
Mathematik Taschenrechner Jura
bürgerliches Gesetzbuch Physik
Formelsammlung Grundschullehramt
Wasserfahrt Malkasten BWL Umschlag mit
dieser Schein für den Professor das
stimmt
was ich da für Stories mitbekomme von
irgendwelchen Kollegen die an
irgendwelchen Privatschulen keine Ahnung
was studiert haben da kommst Du wirklich
mit Geld durch meine Mutter hat sich
gerade aufgeregt warum Mama Doppelpunkt
wenn der Geschirrspüler voll ist kannst
du ihn auch ruhig anmachen ich mache
auch keine an wenn ich voll bin
was
ja
die Wahrheit als Pilot würde ich ja
versehentlich das Mikrofon für die
Durchsagen anlassen und sagen mit dem
Jochen Schweizer Erlebnisgutschein darf
ich das Ding echt ganz alleine fliegen
das
wenn ich das hören würde im Flugzeug ne
ich würde
ich hätte schon Todesangst aber ich
würde es auch richtig feiern und
ablachen glaube ich meine Freundin will
abends nicht weil sie am nächsten Tag
fit sein muss meine auch mach das für
euch Frauen echt so ein riesen
Unterschied ob ihr um 22:30 Uhr oder
22:31 Uhr schlafen gehen und an der
Stelle meine
[Musik]